اليوم الرابع عشر بعد المئه لازال القصف
الاسرائيلي متواصل صباح هذا اليوم غزه
شاهد على مجزره جديده بحق عائله سلميا
الذي التي ارتقى بها ثمانيه افراد سته
منهم من الاطفال لكن هذا الرجل هو من رجال
الدفاع المدني الذي قصف منزله في منطقه حي
الزيتون نحن نتحدث الان ايضا عن معدات
الدفاع المدني المتهالكه التي قصفت بفعل
قوات الاحتلال مرات عديده واستهدف استهدف
رجال الدفاع المدني ايضا مرات اكثر هذه
اثار القضايا الاسرائيليه والطلقات
الاسرائيليه التي تظهر بشكل جلي وبشكل
علني على سياره الاسعاف التي كانت تحاول
واثار الشظايا الاسرائيليه التي كانت
تحاول دائما انقاذ حياه وارواح المواطنين
لكن اصبح هذا هؤلاء الرجال ضمن بنك اهداف
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وا يعني هذه السياره
الوحيده نتحدث عنها لسياره الاطفاء
الموجوده في شمال او في مدينه غزه
بالتحديد وهي ال المعدات البسيطه التي
يمتلكها الدفاع المدني على الرغم من ذلك
مستمره الطواقم بالعمل مستمره بتواجدها
شمال قطاع غزه وايضا مستمره في انقاذ حياه
ارواح الناس رغم انهم قتلوا هم وعائلاتهم
من قوات
الاحتلال